the Joe Rogan experience don't get in
your own head back let it go
[Music]
my granddad was a soldier on the front
in 41 the bullets took his brothers but
stubborn lock held on the sky was filled
with fire millions lost and flame
hate and love we're all there in the
world that are the same
some days will sink in sadness in the
way of them too
don't lose yourself to madness the way
out is love
when the New York towers crumble we were
all New Yorkers to for a moment all just
human got the same old red blue the
wicked I'll go on scheming for the power
the heart longs for freedom it's a fire
they'll never tame
some days will sink in sadness a way of
them to enter
lose yourself to madness the way how is
love
the virus took our comfort
it was never ours to own
when the enemy's insider but together
about a loan
this life is so damn fragile Alif car by
the wind but every veterans tragic
nights a hope within
some days will sink and sadness the way
of them to talk don't lose yourself to
madness the way
[Music]
[Applause]